in Germany they are gonna have public
nudist spaces in the city not just the
beaches that's right they're gonna have
six urban naked zones around the city
where people will be free to sunbathe
naked we don't have any images for this
sorry but as we just said in the video
there's plenty of porn online hey guys
just ask nicely this is where everyone
comments on Gina's boob making urban
naked zone right yes so there this
started because there was an expiration
of legislation for nude sunbathing in
Bavaria
of which Munich is the capital and city
leaders had to decide can people strip
in public now or what so they're just
gonna have these little naked zones and
this is literally gonna be like there's
gonna be people working in offices and
then just you know a few feet away some
naked zones we could never do this could
we you know and they shouldn't do it in
Germany because Germany Germany's [ __ ]
up and it's always been [ __ ] up and
this is just another [ __ ] up thing
like I just leads to a weird political
party doesn't it no well it does we lead
to a political party that's a great
point but you know we were just talking
about the porn story and like when you
watch porn and then you stumble on
German porn you realize oh dear God yeah
Jesus I hope she's okay can you explain
a little boy I honestly I'm not really
sure with German porn is but every time
we've done a thing on porn in this
someone says that about German porn and
then people start going what's the deal
with German border aggressive very
progressive there's a lot of choking it
regard yet it's not uh it's not I mean
I've only watched like 1520 hours a day
right I will turn no it's a you know one
of the first of the Gentiles a great
store one of the first videos when he
was given it did you know of VHS poor
was german porn yeah and one of the
lines personal everything said in even
like you know oh baby it feels so good i
just want to be inside you make you feel
wonderful
even that sounds hideous in german but
there's a line in there
I'm gonna get it slightly wrong but it's
essentially snoopin dash dash's Vita
mean right which just again sounds like
paper super does doesn't be too mean it
means
drink it up if I might fight it up
please because I love where this is
going
but I think that that's I think that
that's a major comment on on our society
and how we feel about nudity because I
don't think that these people that this
culture equates nudity with porn I mean
there's but you know they go with their
families they go with their little kids
I lived in Greece for a very small
amount of time and we would go to the
nude beaches and I promise you not only
were these not you know hyper sexual
people they were not hyper sexually
attractive people these are people who
like to be naked and it doesn't mean
anything other than that right so in
Europe it's just people that like to be
naked versus here are nude beaches it's
always like a lot of old men hiding
behind a bush like yes fondling himself
exactly been you've been there that's
where we met I think but I think Gina's
right he did and I I think the nudists
would would would bristle at the notion
that we want to sexualize there yeah
their desire to be new is there
something a little funny about the
geographic location of this that it
really is going to be pretty much in
urban areas as if these naked people
have to get naked like they're there at
work and they're all day long they're
like oh geez it's close you drive of
maybe I love that I think that's so
great yeah yeah they just they can't
keep it their clothes on if I might
anecdotally tell you a few weeks ago I
may or may not have been at a
clothing-optional spa in Palm Springs
and you're welcome and yep which option
did you take here's the thing these
people I mean yeah there's there's
probably people out there that do it for
like you know other reasons but this
particular hotel was just people who
just aren't feeling it just aren't
feeling clothes so that's the thing I
think that these German people there's
not into it man
so was you're walking around like be at
the bar and there be a naked guy and
he'd be like hey what's going on and
that was
they go back to his room and waters real
cold my apologies yeah it's just not a
big deal yeah so and I you know whatever
you know did you have any guy say to you
hey hey
my mouth is up here well you know I'm
from Kansas so I'm I'm obviously you
know a liberal you know super open
hippie but you know if you could just
excuse that that's a thing like it's
it's it's not a big deal to most of the
world I don't know about most of it so a
lot of the world and if Germans want to
sit in the park alfresco I'm I think
that's great well I didn't know we
actually had a legit nudists on the snow
if you do either
what made you want to go there well it's
not my view what yeah what made you want
to go like you were just like yeah let
me try it on I think it's pretty great
do you wanna know what brought me there
this would be like a 442nd story go
alright so I was in the desert with some
friends I'm already bored you can shut
it I was in the desert with some friends
late in the day and they were like I'd
love to go to a mineral spa I was like I
think it's a little late for that I
think they're all closing I'll see what
I can do and I called this one I just
randomly found it my phone I was like I
don't know I'll try them they're on
Google I called and I said hi are you
still open do you you know to the
clothing
spa and like oh we're closed I'm so
sorry I was like I no big deal he goes
what's your name and I said Gina and he
goes and we talk for a few minutes goes
let me call you right back
so he calls me right back he goes Gina I
like the cut of your jib
he said you sound like a really really
honest person you sound like a really
trustworthy person I'd like you a lot
tell you what I'm gonna do we're gonna
leave you the key
what oh I swear to God are you sure you
didn't just end up at some old herbs
house swear dude we thought it was gonna
be the world's worst David Lynch movie
but we get there and there are people
there and it's like there's like goddess
statues and like these fountains and
it's so beautiful and we pushed in the
co2 we open it's like [ __ ] shangri-la
and I'm like well when in Rome so we had
an amazing time and I have a really
trustworthy voice
[Music]